so if I know you I love you oh yes you
really like yourself Meredith you're one
of our favorite Grey's Anatomy
characters of all time you went from
being referred to as the girl in the bar
to mrs. Derek Shepherd to Widow gray but
now they're calling you Wonder Woman for
obvious reasons as the head of general
surgery at grey-sloan Memorial Hospital
you've witnessed your fair share of
tragedies but your life hasn't always
been picture-perfect either and you know
more than anyone that things don't
always go as planned still you always
manage to get back to you
Grey's Anatomy is one of the
longest-running series in US history but
with so many storylines in character
arcs it's only normal that the series
has a handful of potholes keep watching
to find out which inconsistency has bugs
fans since it first popped up in season
six be professional do my job I like my
job Joe Wilson's a legal name change
let's kick things off with Joe Wilson or
should we say Brooks Sadler Joe's big
reveal had fans collecting their jaws
off the floor it was so shocking that it
took us a while to realize that her
story just didn't add up
when Alex proposed to Joe everyone was
stunned when she said no because well
they were perfect for each other it was
until the day before the Alex DeLuca
trial that we found out the real reason
she didn't accept Alex's proposal as it
turns out Joe couldn't accept it because
she was already married I'm married
how are you talking about now let's take
things way back to before Joe got a job
at the grey Sloan Memorial Hospital back
then when Joe was Brooke she was married
to an abusive husband named Paul Stadler
when Brooke ran away
Paul swore that if she ever filed for
divorce he would find her immediately
so Brooke changed her name to Joe Wilson
and the rest is pretty much history but
wait how does that make any sense why
would Joe be scared of testifying if she
had legally changed her name and how
could Joe have become a doctor without
the proper documentation this loose end
was buried under a devastating story of
domestic abuse
so this pothole was missed by a lot of
viewers but for some reason it was too
great to ignore
Amelia's brain tumor the doctors at
grey-sloan Memorial Hospital don't have
it easy on top of living super hectic
lives they're constantly put in
life-threatening situations and let's
not forget that many times these
characters have gone from doctor to
patient when we found out that Amelia
Shepherd had a huge and severe brain
tumor we thought she was a goner for
sure but that's not how things played
out the thing is brain tumors are super
serious and we've seen time and time
again how devastating and crippling
brain surgery can be I don't know it's
me and was tumor talking about I love
you people tremendously most patients
don't walk away from a surgery without
some life-changing repercussions but
Amelia's tumor was removed like it was
no big deal
and she recovered as easily as someone
would from a common cold it just didn't
make sense
viewers couldn't help but feel like
Amelia's storyline was solely used to
stir the pot her speedy recovery was
nothing short of inconsistent Meredith
for the win Meredith has been through so
much from losing her mother best friend
half-sister and husband to drowning in a
ferry accident and so much more
Meredith's life is literally a
merry-go-round of disaster so we were
super happy for her when she won the
prestigious Harper Avery award in fact
we're so happy for her we almost
overlooked the major plot hole the show
created when they granted Meredith this
great honor the Harper Avery surgical
innovation goes to dr. Meredith Grey do
you remember when Cristina Yang was
nominated for that very same award in
season 10 well then you probably
remember the reason Richard Webber
couldn't choose her as a winner as it
turns out the former Seattle Grace
Hospital was co-owned by the Harper
Avery foundation so there was a major
conflict of interest but somehow in
season 14 Meredith won this award
despite still being associated with that
very same hospital we're still waiting
for an explanation if you've got one
leave it in the comments section
easy dates to patient you ready as he
has done some pretty wild things for
love but nothing compares to when she
cut Denny's LVAD wire to get him higher
up on the transplant list can you say
illegal we never understood how is ease
tampering didn't end with her doctor's
license being revoked granted she was an
intern at the time but that's beside the
point
everyone acted like Izzie and Denny's
relationship wasn't against the rules
but it was doctors aren't supposed to
engage in relations with their patients
it can cause a major complications which
is exactly what happened in Grey's
Anatomy to make matters worse Denny's
heart transplant didn't go as planned
and he soon had a stroke and passed away
Izzie was selfish and made sure that the
heart went to Denny when it could have
gone to someone else and actually saved
their life if this had happened in real
life he would be behind bars stick
around until the end to find out which
other major plot holes involving Izzie
has bugs fans for well over a decade
Derek's secret fling before Derek fell
in love with Meredith he was pining
after his wife Addison who had cheated
on him with his old friends mark
so Derek knew exactly how it felt to get
cheated on but that never stopped him
from locking lips with Renee Collier
while being in a committed relationship
with Meredith now don't get us wrong
Derek and Meredith will forever be the
strongest ship Grey's Anatomy has to
offer but we were stunned when Derek
chose not to tell Meredith about his
run-in with Renee after some digging we
found out that Derek did in fact how
Meredith about his fling in a deleted
scene says she wasn't important says he
didn't cheat but the scene was cut from
the show so in the end it's as if Derek
chose to withhold this information
because he was afraid that Meredith
wouldn't take him back as it turned out
no one is perfect
McDreamy included here are the things we
love everything from Disney movies like
frozen to dramatic TV like Grey's
Anatomy if you'd like to stay up to date
with the latest TV trends subscribe to
the things and click that Bell to be
notified whenever we post a new video if
you're watching on your phone go into
YouTube settings and turn on
notifications
April's morals go out the window when
April Kepner was first introduced in
season six she quickly gained a
reputation for being Little Miss Perfect
for a super long time April kept her
relationship with God top secret because
she didn't want the other doctors to
judge her she was a devout Christian who
was saving herself for marriage and her
morals were the utmost importance to her
now it's only normal for characters to
have arcs so we were expecting his shift
in April's personality but we never once
thought it would happen so quickly the
night before the residents had their
medical boards April chose to throw her
morals out the window she slept with
Jackson out of the blue which seriously
messed with her head we were all for the
April Jackson's storyline but a lot of
fans think that April's character change
was much too drastic and super
unrealistic my God my God why have you
forsaken me
the custody battle once upon a time in
Seattle Callie and Arizona were one of
the cutest couples in town but things
started to get a little messy when
Callie had a fling with Mark and ended
up pregnant
Callie Arizona and Mark agreed to be
co-parent and things were going smoothly
for quite some time that is until mark
passed away in a plane crash that would
also leave Polly with an amputated leg
these life-altering events would lead to
Callie and Arizona's divorce and soon
Callie would start dating penny and
dream of moving to New York with her new
girlfriend and daughter Sofia problem
was Sophia was Arizona's daughter too
and she wasn't about to let her go
without a fight
there is a messy custody battle and
Callie was eventually granted sole
custody are we the only ones who think
this storyline was super inconsistent we
mean Sophia had just lost her father and
Callie was ready to move to New York
leaving her daughter's second mother
behind to make matters worse poor Sophia
had to go through a stressful custody
battle only to end up moving away with
Callie and penny anyway no matter what
the judge decides Derek's demise it was
no secret that actor Patrick Dempsey who
portrayed Derek Shepherd wanted out of
Grey's Anatomy but after being a prime
member of the cast for a total of 11
seasons getting rid of him wouldn't be
easy in season 11 episode 21 Derek's
life met an abrupt end when he came
face-to-face with a semi-truck fans
weren't too happy about the way Derek
left the show especially since his
demise would be viewed as a major
pothole while on his way to quit the
president's brain mapping project in
Washington Derek came across an accident
and pulled over to help he saved a young
girl and her mother as well as another
couple but before Derek could get back
into his car and drive away he was hit
by an oncoming truck so here's the plot
hole why didn't dare eat check before
crossing the road and why didn't he hear
the truck coming it's not like he was in
a crowded place with lots of noise
quite the contrary really he should have
heard that truck coming from a mile away
what happened to Addison when we first
met Addison Montgomery and season 1 of
Grey's Anatomy
we immediately don't like her after all
she did cheat on McDreamy Meredith and
Addison bumped heads for quite some time
before burying the hatchet
Addison eventually left the show when
her character was given her very own
spinoff series if I hadn't been here
today if you'd had someone else that
girl would have died delivering her baby
but if there's one thing that's bugs
fans ever since Derek's demise it's how
Addison never made an appearance at her
ex-husband's funeral we get it she's
busy and all but she's not heartless so
why didn't she show Izzy's medical bills
as he might have made some bad decisions
in the past but we never viewed her as a
bad person but that all changed when she
was fired from the grey Sloan Memorial
Hospital convinced that Alex got her
fired
he left her husband without ever giving
him an explanation what's worse is that
she stuck him with her medical bills and
let's just say that cancer treatment
isn't cheap for an entire episode Alex
was super stressed out over all the
money he owed but whether he paid her
medical bills or not was never revealed
this season six plot hole still bugs us
until this very day we all know why
Katherine Heigl's character was given a
bad rap on the show after all
Katherine's seriously messed up when she
withdrew herself from the 2008 Emmy race
stating that the material didn't warrant
an Emmy nomination and I'm not going to
apologize for that
I'm not a rude person I'm not an unkind
or mean person Shonda Rhimes fired back
by giving Izzie the worst character arc
of all time
but even then fans want to know what
happened to the Izzie stifling medical
debt and that's it for the 10 major plot
holes in Grey's Anatomy we hope you
liked our video before you go tell us
who your favorite character is and why
sound off in the comments
thanks for watching don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see you
next time on the things